foreign
so I found this in the wild actually
Bill Maher had Kevin nealan on which by
the way I love Kevin I think he's
[ __ ] hilarious but um they're talking
about Howard Stern and this is some
stuff now merch brought something up
Bill Mars and Howard turned a lot like
he was some great bits he was the one
with Howard Stern too he did the talk
show where uh they were asking very
questions but they had like Daniel
Carver from the KKK and they had a
Beetlejuice that was so good and they
had like Bill Maher looked like really
like Jesus's [ __ ] guy even back then
he was like disgusted with him it's when
they were called the retards not the
whack pack either and you dude you're
going to talk about this used to go out
on E like you gotta remember this was a
different time right yeah he couldn't
curse as much on TV but like the
e-network would air the uncut Daniel
Carver where they'd be like so what do
you think that Daniel tell Bill Moore
about some of your like why you think
the country's going to [ __ ] well I mean
because you got these Jews and these and
what they're doing out here and it's
like he would just say it all man and
you could just see Bill Moore like this
like oh well okay then like it was dude
it was genuine revulsion bro you're
never gonna get that kind of [ __ ] ever
again Howard Stern oh wow and I always
avoid the stern because I knew he put
people on the spot and he makes you kind
of bad mouth other people but for some
reason I started listening to his
interviews he got a lot better at not
doing that but I went on there prepared
for anything and he came out and he was
so nice he was so nice to me you know I
I have a long storied history ups and
downs with that man and it says I find
it so sad these days that I can't see
him because of the pandemic and you know
we don't agree on that not that that I
think has made us not like each other
because we didn't have a good
relationship for a very long time very
bad why what happened and he's right and
Bill's got a good point Bill's like I
can't even see you now because if you go
to the Howard Stern Show now and some
people know that some people don't but
we've said it a couple times
Howard Stern if you when you when you
just like saw Bob Odenkirk on the
Republic was on there recently he is in
New York in Howard Stern studio with the
multi-million dollar serious Studio but
he's talking to a monitor with Howard's
face on it Howard hat is Palm Beach home
studio turned into look exactly like the
studio and then he makes everyone else
still come in though except if you look
at the tile floor
it's different flooring and unless
you're the [ __ ] autism you're paying
and I did look at the flooring it's
different flooring so and and of course
they're told the celebrities are told
not to mention that Howard's in a
different Studio how that's what he's
doing I don't want to talk to a [ __ ]
TV that's weird but he still makes
everyone else come in right like
everyone else is still everyone has to
go into his studio in New York like they
can't Skype in like Bob odenker couldn't
Skype in for example and this is his
house in the Hamptons or in Florida in
Palm Beach Florida so he's just in
Florida now yeah he's 99. he got that
idea from Space Ghost I know I know I
from my understanding I don't think
Howard has left Florida since the
beginning of the pandemic that makes no
sense to me because if he's so terrified
of this [ __ ] game that make then why
did he stay in the state where you know
everybody's a dirty [ __ ] because
they let him build the studio in his
[ __ ] house
and then boy it all changed and it just
shows there's some great things about
age and getting older and wiser and
mellower and smarter and and and we
became such good friends again this is
like a romantic story like you know
Bogey and then they met in Casablanca
and it was going to be good again and
then the war came and in this case the
pandemic came and I don't think I'll
ever see him again because I don't think
he'll ever leave the house and look Bill
Maher I I blame him a lot for a lot of
stuff but the one thing I've always even
before the one thing I've always given
Bill more credit is for two things
he can be very funny
you and I always I don't care what your
political leanings are you can be very
funny
and Bill Maher will be stubborn even if
it's people don't agree with him I give
him credit for that you know because
he's still been like I don't this
pandemic stuff remember when they try to
rip him apart he says look I got
vaccinated I took him for the team I
don't even want to remember they're
trying to rip him apart for that
because he's well no you know he's very
very
um yeah he's all right he gets called
all right like once a month no more bro
he's a lefty
look I didn't want to judge it but he's
scared of germs come on I mean
you know he said people I mean it says
Howie Mandel but that guy still leaves
his home not only that Howie Mandel has
a new podcast yeah when people come into
His studio in front of him dude he's
been shaking hands he's been shaking
hands and stuff too because how he's
been the opposite I always always wanted
to get better
he has always said that he's like tried
to work because I've really he said I
really try
about that and they're allowed I don't
agree with look it's at least he went
from like he would only fist bump people
to now Howie Mandel will shake their
hands he will still [ __ ] squirt a
little [ __ ] sanitizer on it but hey
you know what he's [ __ ] trying that's
yeah but that's I wouldn't take that
from somebody if it makes you feel
better that's fine it's just be normal
try to meet in the middle be social but
I don't care if I'm not gonna be
insulted if you use hand sanitizer for
the car whatever I know my hands are
clean but I don't care do whatever you
want some things he said about the
pandemic I think were very to me if I if
I if I shake your hand and then you
immediately use hand sanitizer that's
like me handing you cash and you
counting it yeah I'll take it as an
insult you're just verifying yeah wrong
you know we shouldn't treat people who
don't get vaccinated stuff like that
that's always been controversial and
things I remember didn't you say
something about recycling that it wasn't
good
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and I think you say those things just to
get ruffle feathers and get a
conversation I've never ever never did
that never ever once in my life uh well
I mean on television Anyway said
anything I don't believe just to be
controversial no okay and I think you
know when you look at what I've said it
doesn't
even Kevin Neal and you saw them doing
it was like you don't even really
believe that stuff though right you're
seeing it to me you're still on he's
like no I [ __ ] do believe it though
like I'm sorry this pisses you off